hey Vsauce Michael here text the printed
word vitally important but never naked
when words and letters are printed they
have to wear the clothing of a typeface
a font family we don't always think of
it this way but you cannot type without
using a typeface even right now here on
YouTube when you leave a comment you are
communicating your own words your own
thoughts but through the visual stylings
of someone else the creator of Arial in
these Vsauce videos Jake Kevin myself
and others use Alcina
because it most closely resembles the
handwriting of Nick Punta the creator of
the vsauce logo now thinking of
typefaces as fashion for letters is not
a new idea
Adrian Frutiger famously said that the
work of a type designer is just like the
work of a dressmaker or as Alan Fletcher
put it a typeface is an alphabet in a
straitjacket some typefaces have serifs
and some don't some are famously neutral
while others are silly or ugly but one
typeface is so silly and so ugly and so
popular that it has arguably become the
most hated font of all time Comic Sans
people who consider themselves
discerning designers scoff at its
Ubiquiti usually wielded by amateurs who
don't know better it was recently
reported that on Twitter
the only thing complained about more
often than Justin Bieber but less
frequently than Airlines is comic
online you can play a kill comic sans
game and the website ban Comic Sans
provides a gigantic list of handwritten
looking fonts that they would prefer you
use instead Comic Sans is so hated
it's almost pulled a 360 and is cool
again ironically David O'Reilly amazing
t-shirts for example but irony isn't the
only thing Comic Sans has going for it
the British dyslexia Association
considers Comic Sans a particularly good
font for children who have trouble
reading letters because of its easily
distinguishable characters like the
letter A for most of our history books
and signs had to be hand written often
meticulously and expensively copied by
hand there were no printers no
typesetters if you wanted a book someone
had to literally write by hand the whole
book for you but Gutenberg changed that
by popularizing interchangeable type he
modeled his type pieces after the
handwriting of scribes at the time
producing what could be called the very
first font ever texture ah later on
typesetters in italy realized that words
could be slanted and remain legible and
readable but take up less vertical space
so more could be printed on a single
page that's why it's called italics not
because italics means slanted or oblique
but because of where it was invented
italy metal type pieces had to be cast
from molten metal in foundries which get
their name from the french fondue which
means something that has been melted and
so it's because of the word fondue that
we now call a collection of characters
within a typeface a font when setting
type typesetters kept their type pieces
in cases the most commonly used pieces
were kept in the lower case for easy
access
whereas capitals were kept just a little
above in the
upper case back to Comic Sans Comic Sans
was designed in 1994 by Vincent Conair
according to the BBC melinda gates
herself asked Conair to design a font
for the cartoon dog in Microsoft Bob to
speak in and so within three days Conair
had designed Comic Sans based on
hand-drawn fonts from comic books it
never actually made it into the final
version of Microsoft Bob but was
subsequently released as a font choice
on so many Microsoft products that it
became what it is today
millions of amateurs now had access to
this font which seemed simple and cute
and became popular on things like
homemade birthday cards but also in less
appropriate situations for instance on
an official Canadian coin or on a
gravestone because of things like that
Comic Sans has amassed a lot of haters
but it was never intended to be used so
often or in such inappropriate
situations and so in reality the fault
may lie with us the typers Comic Sans
doesn't disappoint people people
disappoint people another way to think
of it as this discerning type
aficionados may recognise Comic Sans so
quickly
because it is a threat type design is a
specialized discipline but now anybody
with a computer can take a stab at it
without your approval they don't need
you to be sure
Comic Sans objectively speaking isn't
really that well designed according to
the fundamentals of type design
David Qaddafi has a brilliant
explanation of this in his why you hate
Comic Sans he points out that it's
unbalanced and not very well kerned
Comic Sans is certainly not a calculated
precise font like Trajan but it's not
organic
like real handwriting instead it lies
within the uncanny valley this concept
often comes up in robotics the more
human something gets the cuter it
becomes the more we like it until it's
almost human but not quite at this point
things become creepy almost scary
perhaps Comic Sans exists in that same
area typographically speaking but that
said the screens that Comic Sans was
originally designed to appear on we're
typically aliased and as qaddafi points
out compared to fonts like Garamond
Comic Sans does really well here that is
how we should think about Comic Sans a
pragmatic font a font that worked
remarkably well in its era and exists
today as one of the most recognizable
relics of one of the most important
design revolutions in history books used
to be painstakingly copied by hand now
later you could design a story or an
idea but the final look really just came
down to what a few typesetters could do
today almost anyone can dabble in
typography and that is an amazing thing
sure it means that Comic Sans will be
used a lot but as Corey Holmes points
out Comic Sans is proof that design
works the public understands that type
means more than words and David Qaddafi
argues that just as interchangeable type
led to a spread of literacy Comic Sans
and the personal publishing it comes
along with should lead us toward a
spread of design literacy
sure Comic Sans is a bit ugly but it's
ugly in the same way that the first few
cords of smoke on the water are ugly as
played by almost every beginning
guitarist who picks up a guitar at
almost every instrument store sure it
sounds annoying and a little bit
fumbling but it represents someone who
is using tools to move toward mastery
Adrian Frutiger said that type has the
power to make the whole world of thought
legible simply by rearranging the same
letters over and over again well Comic
Sans overused by the untrained majority
may seem unsavory to some people but as
such it most loudly represents something
phenomenal today it is possible for the
whole world of thought to be made
legible and be shared by the whole world
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]